as a small
tangent or actually a very big tangent
but uh proof
compilation is a beautiful concept
in a sense the way of doing physics
with this model is by
running it or compiling it
and yes it have you thought about
and these things can be very large is
there totally
new possibilities of
computing hardware and computing
software
which allows you to perform this kind of
compilation
well algorithms software hardware so so
first comment is
these models seem to give one a lot of
intuition about distributed computing
a lot of different intuition about how
to think about parallel computation
and that particularly comes from the
quantum mechanics side of things which
we didn't talk about
much yet but uh the question of what
you know given our current computer
hardware how can we most efficiently
simulate things yeah
that's actually partly a story of the
model itself because the model itself
has deep parallelism in it
yes the ways that we're simulating it
we're just starting to be able to use
that deep parallelism
to be able to be more efficient in the
way that we simulate things
but in fact the structure of the model
itself
allows us to think about parallel
computation in different ways
and one of my realizations is that you
know so
it's very hard to get in your brain how
you deal with parallel computation and
you're always worrying about
you know if multiple things can happen
at different on different computers at
different times
oh what happens if this thing happens
before that thing and we've really got
you know we have these race conditions
where something can race to get to the
answer
before another thing and you get all
tangled up because you know which thing
is going to come in first
and usually when you do parallel
computing there's a big obsession to
lock things down to the point where
you've
you've had locks and mutexes and god
knows what else
where where you've you've um you've
arranged it so that there can only be
one sequence of things that can happen
so you don't have to think about all the
different kinds of things that can
happen
well in these models physics is throwing
us into
forcing us to think about all these
possible things that can happen but
these models
together with what we know from physics
is giving us new ways to think about
all possible things happening about all
these different things happening in
parallel
and so i'm guessing they have built-in
protection for some of the parallelism
well causal invariance is the built-in
protection causal and variance is what
means
that even though things happen in
different orders it doesn't matter in
the end
as a as a as a person who struggled with
concurrent programming
in in like java
uh with all all the basic concepts of uh
concurrent programming
that that if there could be built up a
strong mathematical framework
for causal and variance that's so
liberating
and that that could be not just
liberating but really powerful for
massively distributed computation
absolutely no i mean you know
what's eventual consistency in this in
distributed databases
is essentially the causal invariance
idea yeah okay so that's
but have you thought about uh
you know what like really large
simulations yeah i mean i'm also
thinking about
look the fact is you know i've spent
much of my life as a language designer
right so i can't
possibly not think about you know what
does this mean
for designing languages for parallel
computation in fact
another thing that's one of these you
know i i'm always embarrassed at
how long it's taken me to figure stuff
out but you know back in the 1980s i
worked on trying to make up languages
for parallel computation
i thought about doing graph rewriting i
thought about doing these kinds of
things but i couldn't see how to
actually make the connections
to actually do something useful i think
now
physics is kind of showing us how to
make those things useful
and so my guess is that in time we'll be
talking about you know we do parallel
programming
we'll be talking about programming in a
certain reference frame
just as we think about thinking about
physics in a certain reference frame
it's a certain coordination
of what's going on we say we're going to
program in this reference frame oh let's
change the reference frame to this
reference frame
and then our program will seem different
and we'll have a different way to think
about it
but it's still the same program
underneath
you